okay rudd asks how common are founder vc
disputes
is there a rank of vcs by how founder
friendly they are
curious if this has gotten better or
worse over time great so there isn't a
list
of like here's a bunch of vcs who fight
with founders
and one thing to understand is sometimes
the founders are wrong sometimes you
know
it's a two-way street here and uh as
many times as i've seen
uh vc you know on the margins
you know let's call it less than five
percent of the time
be difficult i've seen founders be
difficult ten percent of the time let's
say
so you're dealing with highly driven
highly opinionated people
if you're doing this right so you should
expect that people will not always see
eye to eye
what you want to do is see if they're
classy even in that so i've had run-ins
with founders who i disagree with what
they were doing
maybe they were doing something i
thought was unethical maybe they were
doing something
that i thought was selfish or not fair
to their team
or just something i wasn't morally or
ethically copacetic with
and i would just say to them very simply
listen i don't have a tankers
relationship with you
uh do you want to buy my shares or maybe
i sell you about half my shares i'll let
the other half
ride and you just take them off your
your page and you don't have to have me
on the investor page anymore
so that's what i try to do because this
is a high-stakes game you can't expect
everybody to get along all the time
um and most people would argue
that it is uh the scales tipped over the
last decade to being
very very founder-friendly in fact most
people would say
founders have too much power voting
shares control of their companies
didn't used to be the standard it used
to be vcs controlled the company could
fire the founders at any time
now the founders can just run amok like
the founder of wework did
um and there is no way to control them
right so
we've seen both sides of this uh
zuckerberg answers to nobody
um and do we see the ramification of
that he's got a bunch of yes
uh men and women on his board a bunch of
yes men and women in his company and
uh and for better or worse you know
maybe for the better of the stock price
he can act unilaterally
but not having a check and balance in
that case could lead to the company
imploding right and i think that's the
existential risk when
any one party has too much power the vc
or
the founder and i wish we had some
balance here in equilibrium
and you typically see that balance come
when a company raises you know their c
or d rounds usually the boards become
kind of balanced so
it's a great question i wouldn't worry
about this all that much if you're a
founder
what i would do is i would just talk to
other founders the investor
has invested in and just say hey i'm
thinking about going to jason's
accelerator you went to jason's
accelerator
what was it like and if you send that
email to 10 people
if none of them get back to you that
means they don't have anything nice to
say and they don't want to
say something if your phone rings
immediately and somebody says oh my god
it was the greatest experience of my
life
or they respond quickly and say sure
anytime here's my phone number or if
they call you quickly and say
oh that was a disaster uh you know i got
nothing out of it
that's that's what you're gonna find out
real quick and so you get but you gotta
send five or ten of those emails to get
a really good representative
sample size so great question and
just like the vc is gonna research you
and diligence you you got a diligence
your vcs and i don't see founders do it
enough great question rudd